all right all right
it's finally time to address it been a
lot of rumors going around a lot of
unfair characterizations character
assassinations
and i want to address them all in one
video
all the baseless rumors that have been
going on about me
[Music]
you know before i became the victim of
hobophobia
i used to think that conspiracy theories
online were just a joke who
really believes after all that flat
earth is real but
quickly after becoming the victim of a
conspiracy theory myself i quickly
realized that
things like this need to be nipped in
the bed
because a dangerous rumor got started in
the last episode
i showed my full body and a lot of you
responded by saying i look like bilbo
baggins
now i know what you're thinking you're
saying stephen it's just a few comments
but the problem is it never stops with a
few comments people started sending me
photoshops that's right photoshops
trying to
indirectly link me to being in a hobbit
trilogy
frankly i think it should be criminally
charged i'm looking into taking legal
action against this man
because i look nothing like a hobbit
and to prove that to you guys because
i'm ending this conspiracy once and for
all let's talk about the pictures
this is a hobbit we look nothing alike
look
see so next time before you share a
baseless conspiracy on
facebook think think about how it
affects you know people like me
anyway that's it